chelsea gabbard knows very well what
wise assessments of crises look like
mitt romney says she should be arrested
for it but she hasn't been yet so she
joins us tonight tells you gabbard
thanks so much for coming on
so thank you
what would be your response to mitt
romney
uh well first of all i think it's
important to point out here that this is
not a matter of disagreement or holding
a dissenting view
this is about facts and this is about
the truth so while senator romney and
all these different talking heads in the
in the mainstream media are
regurgitating hillary clinton's
slanderous talking points
the facts remain number one is they're
accusing me of saying that somehow there
are bioweapons
labs in ukraine i've said no such thing
at any point i have said that there are
bio labs in ukraine that have received
u.s support that contained dangerous
pathogens that if those labs are
breached then then we in the world are
facing a potential future of pandemics
that this is a dangerous crisis that
needs to be addressed immediately these
pathogens need to need to be destroyed
the second thing they're saying is they
deny even though there is a plethora of
evidence that exists they deny that
these bio labs are even there
which is shocking to me that you we've
heard over and over you've played so
many clips from people in the mainstream
media saying these bio labs these
supposed bio labs as though there's some
fantasy
when over and over and over again
officials from our own government
department of state department of
defense and so on are saying
these bio labs in ukraine
have dangerous pathogens and we're very
concerned that they may be breached
that's the concern that i've continued
to raise because it is not left to right
democratic republican this is a serious
safety and health and life concern for
the american people
and people around the world and so the
media is lying uh they're not only lying
about this you saw headlines a couple of
days ago tulsi gabbard paid off by
russian agent
what the media is is lying about is the
fact that uh an american citizen gave my
campaign a 59 contribution coming from a
woman i've never met never talked to
don't know don't know anything about
but somehow they they feel justified in
saying tulsi gabbard is being paid off
the danger in the media lying so
blatantly to the american people these
so-called journalists who have a
responsibility to the public
is it poses a very direct threat to our
democratic republic because they
continue to get away with it they
continue to parrot and propagate these
lies and and they need to be held
accountable they need to be exposed
i just and by the way the u.s government
has said that there are bioweapons in
ukraine they're soviet era bioware over
and over you're going to destroy that we
haven't so they've said that we're just
responding to what they have said
but i wonder if you just quickly assess
the way that people are thinking is what
scares me most we can debate about what
we believe the facts are but if we're
incapable of thinking rationally if our
first instinct is to denounce something
we don't like as treasonous propaganda
and call for a jail sentence
i mean what you know who who's leading
this country
well i think it's important to recognize
that that facts exist
especially in this case facts exist and
the truth is the first casualty of war
and so this is exactly what we are
seeing here people have a very specific
agenda refusing to recognize the truth
refusing to have a conversation and
instead immediately resorting to their
age-old tactic of silence smear
and destroy the character and reputation
of anyone who dares to say anything that
they don't like yeah well thank you for
not being bowed i mean if you care about
the country you clearly do
you know you got to be honest and try
your best to think about the wisest
course forward period regardless of what
they call you and i'm just grateful that
you are doing that tulsi gabbard thank
you hey sean hannity here hey click here
to subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis you will not
get it anywhere else